[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui sera entièrement consacrée à la
question de la laïcité qu'est ce que
c'est la laïcité d'où vient-elle quels
sont les ses textes fondateurs est ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui menacée faut-il
la défendre il ya d'ailleurs un
hors-série de marianne qui paraît ces
jours ci et qui est intitulé qui veut
tuer la laïcité française et marianne
dénonce d'ailleurs des deux dangers
c'est le libéralisme anglo-saxon et
c'est aussi via dément l'islamisme
radical qui entend identifier une
population en fonction de son
appartenance religieuse
si on ajoute à ça ce qui se passe à 6
ont secoué grenoble
si on ajoute à ça la dénégation de de la
jeune fille qui avait dénoncé
samuel pâtit vous voyez que les
questions qui se posent sont nombreuses
et passionnantes et qu'elles posent un
problème grave puisque historiquement la
laïcité la république sont en france
intimement lié voilà pourquoi avec
nathalie wolf nous avons voulu aborder
ce sujet pour jourdain très dis-je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint quentin et vice-doyenne de cette
université
alors jean claverie le bonjour vous êtes
de délégué général du think tank
l'aurore l'aurore en rappel c'est le
journal de cleebourg soe d'isola
référence avouée oui voilà de jor-el de
j'accuse
vous êtes aussi un des fondateurs du
printemps républicain vous avez été
conseiller de françois hollande et vous
êtes l'auteur d'un rapport à la demande
du gouvernement d'edouard philippe sur
la laïcité rapport qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit on en parlera évidemment tout à
l'heure françois voir ton bonjour
bonjour patrice nous est le maire divers
gauche de bruit en cours et j'ai
souhaité vous soyez là parce que d'abord
vous êtes confrontés comme élu à des
vocations de la licité puis vous êtes
aussi un enseignant de casquette on sait
que la laïcité d'enseignement sont
intimement liés stéphane manceau vous
n'avez pas me contredire pintade su
mangeant patrice mangin jours vous êtes
professeur à l'université de versailles
saint quentin et ancien doyen de la
faculté de droit jean-charles lajoie ni
bonjour éditeurs et vous avez aussi
enseignant à l'iut de rambouillet et
vous étudiants ont travaillé justement
sur ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
attraper ce sera très intéressant que
nous raconter de le le rendu de leurs
réflexions
et puis vincent couronne bonjour bonjour
patrese pour tous vous êtes aussi en cd
vous êtes spécialiste de droit européen
vous êtes deux fondateurs de surligneurs
et vous n'y verrez un peu bas comment se
situe la nécessité en europe dans des
pays voisins est ce que c'est une
spécificité française ou est ce que au
contraire elle est étendue donc dans
tous ces pays alors on va commencer peut
être par des définitions va s'interroger
qu'est ce que c'est la laïcité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors articles de la constitution je le
cite la france est une république
indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
tous les citoyens sans distinction
d'origine de race de religion elle
respecte les croyances c'est la
définition de la laïcité ça non oui si
vous voulez bien sûr on va écouter oui
comme comme vous l'avez dit patrice en
effet on a ici et bien tous les éléments
de ce qu'on appelle le socle des valeurs
républicaines et les éléments de
l'article vous ne citez est bien sont le
fruit d'une très longue histoire une
histoire des relations entre les églises
et l'état une histoire qui est faite de
luttes qui est fait d'opposition et qui
a abouti à cette solution originale par
rapport aux autres démocraties
occidentales
et bien c'est la laïcité à la française
alors ça veut dire qu'on a une
séparation absolue des églises et de
l'état tout en consacrant et bien la
liberté religieuse la liberté d'opinion
de conscience comme on fait grâce au
travail des lumières est évidemment de
la révolution française
alors si on essaie d'approfondir encore
un tout petit peu pour comprendre ce que
ça veut dire que ces fondements comment
elle s'est fabriqué cette laïcité à la
française
eh bien on peut revenir à l'étymologie
elle est intéressante étymologie
sismologiques grecs c'est la hausse et
la hausse est bien ça renvoie à quoi ça
renvoie à l'unité d'une population qui
forment un tout indivisible et certain
sens que ça rejoint d'autres mots pour
trouve un dans l'article mans que vous
avez cités patrice et donc ça veut dire
que le lay
c'est l'homme la femme du peuple qui ne
s'élèvent pas au dessus des autres qui
ne dispose d'aucune prérogative qui vont
faire qu'il est qu'il peut s'élever au
dessus des autres et donc il n'est pas
un directeur de conscience il n'impose
pas ce qu'il faut croire ou ne pas
croire
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'elle a hésité elle repose sur deux
mondes la liberté on comprend bien ce
avec votre délégation aurait donc la
liberté c'est aussi la liberté de croire
et de ne pas croire et puis légalité et
en france la particularité ça qui est
parfois mal compris deux de nos amis par
exemple américains ou britanniques
en france on dit que pour garantir à
tous cette liberté que je viens de citer
pour la garantir de manière égale pour
ne pas faire prédominer une religion sur
l'autre eh bien l'état n'ont repris
ville et j aucune ont fait prévaloir
aucune c'est ça vraiment l'égalité la
laïcité à la française et elle repose
sur la laïcité sur lala pardon dans le
lac sur l'égalité et sur la liberté ça
va ensemble sur cette définition vous
avez deux choses allaient gilles covan
non c'est évidemment voilà très juste le
mot peut-être qu'ils ont sur lequel on
insiste peut généralement c'est pourtant
le titre de la loi de 1905 c'est la
séparation
en fait il ya un processus historique
très ancien qui démarre bien avant
l'avant la république et même bien avant
la révolution française et qui voit
l'état au moment où il se forme 13ème
14ème siècle s'autonomiser
progressivement de toutes les autres
formes de tutelle or dans un premier
temps ce n'est pas en repoussant la loi
divine
au contraire c'est en se l'appropriant
contre rome ça c'est une caractéristique
de l'est très particulière de la france
va encore que la fille aînée de l'église
s'était alors voilà c'est c'est pour ça
que les relations que nous entretenons
avec les religions sont parfois un peu
plus ambivalente qu'on aimerait bien le
dire mais dans la danse au processus
historique qui a eu des temps
d'opposition c'est vrai alors c'est je
faisais référence au 14e siècle c'est ce
qu'on appelle la querelle bonifacienne
qui voit s'opposer le pape boniface 8 à
affiner peu lebel alors l'un veut
excommunié l'autre l'autre envoie son
garde des sceaux pour molester le pape
il va mourir d'ailleurs quelques mois
plus tard enfin tout ça prend un tour
extrêmement violent
ça s'est un temps d'opposition il ya eu
aussi des temps d'alliance par exemple
où l'église française se disant
gallicane s'allie avec la royauté contre
rome pour s'autonomiser pour gagner en
indépendance donc les c'est un jeu
extrêmement complexe mais auquel
évidemment les idées des lumières et la
révolution et plus tard lorsque la
république va revenir
la troisième république va apporter un
élément de rupture décisif qui va être
cette idée de séparation donc pas
seulement l'autonomisation de l'état
mais là où
si le fait que la société tout entière
et pas seulement l'état la société toute
entière ne se soutient plus d'une règle
religieuse et ça ça va avoir une
conséquence majeure ça va être que les
pères fondateurs de la troisième
république vont considérer que c'est à
travers l'éducation la ce qu'une
nouvelle une nouvelle comment dire oui
une nouvelle morale sociale en fait
débarrasser l'idée de dieu va devoir
s'imposer ça c'est très important de
vous interroger d'autres c'est vrai que
le premier champ d'action de la laïcité
on le voit avec les premières lois qui
sont de 82 86 puis les lois de jules
ferry
c'est l'éducation l'éducation et la
laïcité et france important vous
intéresserait aussi le tueur sont
intimement liés oui patrice il ya une
contribution une contribution
intellectuelle puissante est
considérable qui est celle de notamment
surtout de mon point de vue de faire
d'une ambition qui est directeur des
enseignements de jules ferry qui est qui
était professeur de littérature et de
philosophie à la sorbonne et on trouve
dans les écrits de ferdinand buisson
qu'il est toujours extrêmement
intéressant de relire vraiment la génèse
de ce que peut être aujourd'hui la
laïcité
et puis la jeunesse de la delà de la
séparation gilles klein clavreul a tout
à fait raison d'insister sur le fait que
ce qui caractérise le les rapports entre
entre l'état et les institutions
religieuses en france c'est d'abord la
séparation
la liberté est à mettre sur le même plan
mais ça la liberté la liberté de
religion de conscience on la retrouve
dans d'autres dans d'autres systèmes
démocratiques mais vous avez raison
la laïcité c'est d'abord celle de
l'enseignement d'un enseignement public
qui se donne pour mission l'émancipation
et l'auto détermination de chacun d'eux
de chacun des élèves et vraiment je
tenais à rappeler la contribution
majeure de ferdinand plus si c'est vrai
qu'on parle moins de ferdinand buisson
que jules ferry et c'est important fonds
sont pourtant justement vous avez été
merde vous avez été enseignant
c'est presque dans l'adn des enseignants
dans la laïcité
d'autres dans tous les cas je parle
évidemment alors oui en tout cas ça ne
devrait pas ce que ce que ce que ce que
je veux dire par là alors je remercie
beaucoup stéphane minson d'avoir évoqué
ferdinand-buisson ghislain acteurs
effectivement important et pour
compléter il a été notamment président
de la ligue de l'enseignement donc donc
c'était un personnage très puissant et
est ce que disait gilles ici présent
c'est aussi que cette loi de 1905 elle
est effectivement l'aboutissement d'un
très long processus et je vous remercie
de l'avoir rappelé j'ai repéré une
petite phrase de jean jaurès en 1904 qui
disait que cette loi justement qu'ils
allaient être votée elle était le terme
logique de l'oeuvre de laïcité
donc c'était vraiment l'aboutissement
mais on en retient souvent que la loi de
1905 et en oubliant probablement un
certain nombre de processus pour revenir
à votre question
alors j'ai j'ai beaucoup milité dans mon
parcours à l'éducation nationale
justement pour que les enseignants
soient sensibilisés effectivement dans
leurs discours à destination de leurs
élèves alors à tous niveaux d'âge mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya probablement des
niveaux d'âge qui qui qui qui sont plus
pertinents que d'autres et pas
simplement au travers des programmes
scolaires trop souvent dans
l'enseignement je pense au collège
puisque c'est un univers que je connais
mieux que les autres
on renvoie ça à des professeurs dont on
pense qu'ils en sont les experts je
pense aux professeurs d'histoire
géographie par exemple moi je considère
qu'un enseignant normalement constitué
dans son parcours et notamment dans son
parcours de formation
il doit être capable d'aborder avec ses
élèves cette question de la laïcité
nathalie vol on doit on a cité ferry
bien sûr mais n'oublions pas quand même
de faire hommage rendre hommage aussi à
condorcet parce que ferry il a un grand
admirateur
voilà c'est condorcet et condorcet c'est
aussi un des pères de la vichy départ on
oublie souvent mais pourtant il est un
des pères de la laïcité mais la laïcité
c'est exactement je rejoins complètement
ce que ce que vous disiez ça va aussi
avec les autres libertés ça va avec la
liberté de la presse en qui va être une
sacrée aussi en 1880 ça va avec la
liberté d'association ça fait partie
vraiment d'un ensemble et condorcet il
va dire au fond que considérer que la
seule autorité légitime à l'école c'est
l'autorité scientifique qui permet de
tout oser examiné de tout oser enseigner
et de faire en sorte c'est très
important
aujourd'hui ça nous paraît presque
normal beffa faut resituer ça on sort
quand même même si vous avez raison il y
avait yavin species ivité 116 mais enfin
on est sorti quand même de dote d'un
ancien régime qui était houleuse la
religion et le pouvoir politique était
extrêmement lié quand même oui c'est ça
il y en a eu six ans l'école au fond et
c'est vraiment ce que ce que va dire
condorcet que va mettre en oeuvre ferry
eh bien on sait ce que c'était femme
disait tout à l'heure je crois que c'est
vraiment important de souligner on veut
faire de l'enfant un sujet rationnel il
va être capable de s'auto conduire et ça
c'est vraiment important et c'est
important aujourd'hui encore permettre
aux enfants de s'auto peut dire c'est le
monde donc on aboutit donc à cette loi
de 10,5 je pense à condorcet où il vient
très beau livre de catherine kintzler
1-0 sur condorcet cette loi de 1905
comment à l'époque c'est quand même la
religion catholique et qui visés par
cette loi
oui alors plus plus encore que la
religion catholique c'est l'église et à
l'intérieur même de l'église sérum parce
que là encore il ya des colères le
disais tout à l'heure il ya des jeux
triangulaire un peu complexe et le
clergé français était pas forcément dans
une hostilité radical de cap à part en
totalité envers la république c'était un
peu plus compliqué que ça mais avec rome
oui très clairement un
une une curie romaine qui depuis les
années 1860 adopté des positions
extrêmement dure contre les mouvements
démocratiques naissants partout en
europe contre les idées universaliste
contre la démocratie contre les idées
socialistes et donc évidemment tout ce
qui se passait en france sur laquelle
rome avait toujours un oeil extrêmement
attentifs et vigilants et est considéré
de manière très négative depuis depuis
le syllabus de 1864 et donc quand on
arrive à la loi de 1905 l'année
précédente il ya déjà eu rupture des
relations diplomatiques entre rome et la
france est donc de fait c'est ça qui a
précipité la loi de 1905
le concordat tomber devenait calude
parce que le concordat en l'oubli c'est
pas seulement un régime de
reconnaissance des religions en france
c'est surtout un traité d'état à état
entre la france et le vatican
donc le concordat tombe en 1904 il faut
il faut un nouveau régime et sur-régime
donc ça va être la loi de séparation
mais alors il est vrai que est un peu
contrairement à la façon dont on a
tendance à le présenter aujourd'hui
c'est pas une espèce de grande de
réconciliation nationale autour d'un
principe qui ferait consensus pas du
tout et il ya une île il ya des
tractations des débats et un accord
final entre républicains après des
débats qui ont quand même été très vif
entre jaurès et clemenceau entre
j'aurais jaurès clemenceau brillant
contre compte voilà
les combis sts qui était plutôt qu'ils
défendent est une vision très très
antique est réglée quand même on
pourrait dire anticlérical et puis
césarienne c'est à dire il y avait
l'idée que le politique devait garder la
main sur sur l'église c'est à dire
continuer à salarier les prêtes pour
pouvoir les contrôler ça se voyait c'est
totalement contraire à l'idée de
séparation et c'est pas l'idée qui s'est
imposé finalement alors autant il ya eu
un consensus mais quand même difficile à
atteindre entre républicains autant le
parti conservateur ce qu'on appelait le
parti clérical effectivement a été très
vite hostiles à la loi de 1905
aiguillonné par rome qui a publié dans
les semaines qui ont suivi la loi de
1905 une bulle enflammé qui s'appelle vm
interne hausse et qui est une
dénonciation en règle au lance flamme de
la loi de 1905 cei a duré assez
longtemps
il va falloir en fait la première guerre
mondiale à la guerre oui la première
guerre mondiale l'union sacrée face à
l'ennemi qui va petit à petit ressouder
la république et les catholiques et donc
au début des années 20 on va rétablir
les relations diplomatiques bon il ya
une espèce de la de consensus qui va
petit à petit se former puis a aussi
quelque chose qui se passe qui échappe
largement aux acteurs c'est que la
france sur banide se sécularise
s'industrialise et le lien social à
l'église tend à s'effacer s'effilocher
et puis bah après dix ans après la
seconde guerre mondiale là ça va
s'accélérer et très très vite on va voir
les indices de pratique religieuse chuté
à mesure que la france s'urbanise se
développe c'est une société qui se
transforme et elle se transforme
clairement au détriment de la pratique
religieuse
natalie wood d'ailleurs il ya peu
contentieux après ils disent on peut
peut-être après la première guerre nous
à la deuxième des rebondeurs de venir il
ya peu de contentieux sur cette question
de la laïcité c'est vrai ça va tout à
fait notre pacification et c'est
intéressant de contentieux de regarder
vraiment les voilà quelles sont les
affaires qui porte sur la question des
cultes parce que ça dit quelque chose de
notre société
alors moi j'avais un peu fait cette
étude vais regarder vraiment toutes les
affaires qui avaient rendu de 1880 à peu
près
en 1981 et dans cette étude me suis
rendu compte que avant la loi de 1905
quelques années après la loi 1905 on va
dire jusqu'en 1915
comme le disait gilles il ya énormément
d'affaires de contentieux alors les les
maires vont aller empêcher les le nombre
des sonneries de cloches la durée la
fréquence de ces sonneries donc on va
vraiment voir le la lutte entre les
républicains et clergé qui va être très
forte et qui va apparaître son plan
contentieux on va avoir des arrêtés
municipaux et préfectoraux qui
interdisent des processions donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup la ferme
beaucoup de jurisprudence et puis qu'est
ce qu'on constate à partir des années 15
20 eh ben il ya presque plus rien et
puis des années 20 aux années 1970 80 et
bien il n'ya presque pas de contentieux
donc ça dit quelque chose d'intéressant
le contentieux s'apaisent les esprits
s'apaisent la sécularisation est en
marche et le contentieux l'éditera bien
prochain moto vous êtes confrontés
parfois en tant que maire des questions
contentieux en matière de laïcité alors
très honnêtement non non non
nous avons la clé les services
techniques de la ville de guyancourt ont
la clé pour aller régler les cloches de
l'église il ya pas que ceci est donc là
il ya une observation
nous en sommes les propriétaires oui
absolument donc donc effectivement est
ce qui permet d'avoir effectivement des
relations apaisées dans mon téléphone
portable
j'ai le numéro du curé numéro des
présidentes messier on est des musulmans
depuis en pole devant l'art ti père
kum-kum non mais avec néanmoins beaucoup
de vigilance avec vous oui c'est vrai
bien sûr mais lazcano on peut être
confronté aussi à des ad on y viendra
peut-être tout à perdre à dire mais à
des associations cultuelles qui vous
demande
voilà leur prêter des lieux etc ça peut
arriver
absolument donc le le fonctionnement
aussi associatif permet effectivement
d'avoir des relations apaisées moi je
trouve
voilà c'est à dire que on peut
parfaitement avoir des mêmes relations
avec une association cultuelle par
exemple l'association l'union des
musulmans du en cours par exemple comme
avec d'autres types d'associations
alalala à la condition de
contractualiser de conventionner d'avoir
un discours clair voilà la non
reconnaissance ça veut pas dire
l'ignorance et ça veut pas dire la
disparition des religions de la vie
publique du tout et c'est cette
confusion on croirait un peu entretenues
et dans la vie locale
moi j'avais connu du côté administration
d'état quand j'étais sous préfet on a
des relations quasiment quotidiennes
avec les représentants des publics parce
qu'il ya plein d'affaires à régler comme
il en a d'ailleurs avec je parlais des
associations sportives éducatives etc et
tout ça fait partie de la vie sociale et
dans l'ensemble ça se passe bien
modulo ce dont on va sans doute parler
après après voilà vincent en un mot
parce que voilà on a bien vu qu'il y
avait une spécificité française la
laïcité en europe elle est quand même
elle est quand même assez répandue alors
oui patrice est là c'est assez répandu
mais sous d'autres formes c'est à dire
qu'on va pas l'appeler laïcité et la
séparation n'est pas aussi absolue comme
le disait nathalie wolf au début que
elle peut l'être en france on set live
comment dire cette séparation entre
entre les églises les religions et
l'état
elle peut prendre diverses formes elle
est le fruit aussi dans ces états là
d'une construction l'ongle souvent de
plusieurs siècles
si on regarde par exemple le modèle
allemand on a une certaine séparation
mais dans laquelle en fait malgré tout
les cultes sont financées par l'impôt et
où les associations cultuelles sont des
associations de droit public
on a le cas grec par exemple il y à là
ici carrément une religion d'état qu'est
la religion orthodoxe comme on a aussi
au danemark comme on aussi à malte et en
grèce les prêtres sont payés sont les
fonctionnaires a payé payé par l'état
on a des systèmes très différents et si
je prends un dernier exemple qui est le
cas de l'italie est assez intéressant
parce que c'est en italie 1 c'est lui au
coeur du territoire italien qu'on trouve
le vatican au coeur de rome
eh bien il ya forcément lissine
spécificité italienne qui fait que les
relations entre le vatican et le reste
de l'italie font que par exemple dans
les écoles publiques en italie et bien
on peut afficher des crucifix dans
toutes les salles de cours et ça ne pose
pas de problème je précise quand même si
on parle d'europe que le l'union
européenne n'a pas son mot à dire sur
l'organisation des cultes la séparation
des églises des états en europe
ce n'est pas du tout une compétence
européenne il ya une limite cependant
c'est là l'interdiction de la
discrimination c'est à dire que on doit
pouvoir traiter tous les citoyens quelle
que soit leur religion de la même
manière et donc ça c'est la seule
intervention si vous voulez européenne
dans les étals la question religieuse
mais de toute façon on voit qu'avec
autant de disparités
il peut pas y avoir un seul son de
cloche si vous me passez l'expression
sur sur le sujet on a vu qu'on aide
était donc à cette période d'apaisement
dont vous parliez de tahiti wolf on va
on va venir au premier tournant c'est la
sphère de treilles et puis après il va y
avoir aussi la sphère de la crèche baby
loup
c'est le tournant book
[Applaudissements]
alors la fin de tracé de 1989
ces deux jeunes filles qui sont au
collège de creil qui sont voilées et qui
sont renvoyés par le proviseur et c'est
vrai que voulez vous les voulez ce
tournant justement de creil alors je ne
les ai pas vécu j'avais 20 ans donc je
n'étais pas encore à l'éducation
nationale mais je m'en souviens
parfaitement oui je m'en souviens
parfaitement
c'est vrai que c'est un tournant un oui
parce que c'est le moment peut-être où
on aurait pu ou affirmé des principes ou
laisser faire
oui c'est toute l'année 89 qui est un
tournant avant de d'entrer dans l'année
dans la sphère de creil et ses
développements 89 c'est bien sûr on a
tous en tête la chute du mur de belle de
berlin est donc l'effondrement du
système communiste
mais avant ça en début d'année le sist
le système communiste va commencé à
s'effondrer en un point très précis
qu'est l'afghanistan avec le retrait des
troupes des troupes soviétiques et qui
repoussait par des combattants qui
combattent au nom d'allah et dans ce
qu'ils appellent le djihad armé à ce
moment-là et soutenu financièrement
équipées et entraînées par l'arabie
saoudite
et parmi les lésés baltes en devenant et
par les américains est parmi les
combattants qu'on va trouver
effectivement soutenu et par l'arabie
saoudite et paralyse américain il ya un
certain oussama ben laden et à un jour
près c'est au mois de février 1989 à un
jour près c'est aussi la publication de
la fatwa contre salman rushdie pour les
versets sataniques donc on voit qu'il ya
une espèce de précipitation de l'ordre
du monde qui bascule de la guerre froide
et de l'affrontement est ouest à un
autre monde alors qu'on a caractérisé de
mille façons depuis nouvel ordre mondial
etc
mais où aussi la question religieuse et
plus particulièrement la question
islamique sous une certaine forme qui
est celle de l'islamisme ou d'ailleurs
des islamistes des islamistes dont il ya
la version chiite de l'imam khomeiny et
puis la version sunnite qui est plutôt
celle
à laquelle on va avoir avec laquelle on
va avoir maille à partir depuis trente
ans et dont kiki et qui est cette
expansion de l'islamisme là dans une
terre très lointaine mais on va voir que
ces affaires-là vont se rapprocher nous
considérablement essentiellement donc
avec cette affaire de creil qui est qui
prend tout le monde à dépourvu au
dépourvu sur les moments survenir dès
que j'y serai une incongruité on voit
beaucoup d'acteurs qui ont du mal à se
positionner alors il y en a un c'est
emblématique
évidemment il ya le ministre de
l'éducation nationale lionel jospin mais
avant ça l'association sos racisme sos
racisme qui est tout de suite évidemment
les projecteurs se braquent sur sos
racisme masqué alors comment vous
considérez ça est ce que c'est une
atteinte à la laïcité il faut
l'interdire est ce que c'est une
discrimination c'est du racisme et donc
vous condamnez pas dans un premier temps
elle souhaite racisme va condamner
l'exclusion des jeunes filles
justement en développant cette
interprétation que la république doit
inclure et que est alors de manière
assez assez ambivalente va dire c'est
par l'inclusion qu'on va aller faire
amener qu'on va les amener à quitter le
voile s'est stabilisé que ce
raisonnement c'est une des soeurs de
l'école c'est un drame parce qu'elles
vont se replier sur la même elles vont
encore ont fait confiance ont leurs
dividendes et c'est réel c'est le temps
le temps et à l'époque françois
mitterrand dans une conversation privée
avec elisabeth badinter qui fait partie
de ceux qui s'opposent à la tolérance
envers le voile est il du bafa vous
elisabeth vous ne croyez quand même pas
que ce sont deux petites filles voilées
qui vont faire trembler la république
d'ailleurs elles sont charmantes dans
quelle espèce de confiance en fait parce
que justement on est on est au terme de
80 ans de paix laïque en gb aucune
raison que ce qui s'est passé pour les
catholiques ne finisse pas par ce passé
de la même façon pour les musulmans et
je reviens sur sos racisme juste un
instant parce que c'est très
emblématique patio est renversée propre
petit à petit sa position et faire en
partant de cette ce point de vue de deux
classiques en fait pour une organisation
antiraciste de contestation de la
décision d'exclusion et bien les
responsables de sos et ils leur disent
non des années plus tard les harlem
désir malek boutih se rendent compte que
derrière les deux collégiennes voilée et
bien il y à des acteurs qui en coulisses
les pousse sur le devant de la scène qui
font un buzz médiatique autour de ça et
ça c'est en fait une une matrice qu'on
va retrouver évidemment dont beaucoup
beaucoup d'affaires depuis 30 ans ou à
partir d'une d'un petit incident d'une
tentative d'une revendication d'une
interpellation d'une provocation
il ya une affaire qui va prendre une
ampleur nationale voire on l'a vu ces
dernières années
international où c'est la france laïque
et mise en procès comme étant non pas
républicaine et égalitaire mais
discriminatoires et racistes voilà et là
il ya un certain nombre d'acteurs de
gauche parce que beaucoup de choses en
fait oui il s'agit de caussade l'espoir
diviser le gypse de la gauche vont se
rendre compte que il ya quelque chose
qui est en train de se passer et que et
que ça va obliger ça va poser ce que
laurent bouvet a appelé la nouvelle
question laïque
alors on va parler des livres dans un
resto peut-être janser le joly et
stéphane minson justement oui cette
affaire de creil là c'est un marqueur
quoi bah oui c'est j'allais dire c'est
presque le début de la fin c'est le
début de la de tout ce qu'on connaît
maintenant effectivement comme
ça me viennent de vienne de l'exprimer
et c'est le début surtout du renoncement
de beaucoup de gens etc
on va très vite s'apercevoir que on ne
peut pas s'exprimer sur le sujet très
rapidement sans être taxé de racisme de
dentiste amusé primaires etc des tout de
suite et les des gens qui sont derrière
ces deux jeunes filles etc
et puis tout cette galaxie sont
extrêmement habile puisque ils vont
capturer le débat interne et voilà toute
personne qui n'est pas pour le port du
voile et qui n'est pas pour cette 6e
sorte de liberté cette reconnaissance de
l'identité de ces jeunes filles et 1 est
en gros un un et est donc c'est à
partir de là de tout le débat est
absolument officiers parce que on est
obligé des comptes dès qu'on dit quelque
chose de prendre un luxe de précautions
oratoires qui nuisent totalement la
clarté du débat fait qu'une fois qu'on a
fini de de s'excuser par avance de ce
que les uns et les autres pu penser on
ne sait absolument plus que la personne
veut dire etc et on a noyé le poisson et
et chaque jour il ya de plus en plus de
femmes voilées il ya plus en plus de 6
et voilà donc on a on a complètement
phagocyté le débat et et j'en veux pour
preuve juste là aussi c'est que on parle
de la laïcité
on a fait une demie-heure passionnante
d'un point d'histoire on en vient
maintenant à ce qui se passe mais là on
n'est plus très vite sur la laïcité
parce que le problème de la laïcité en
fait on n'a pas de problème de laïcité
avec d'autres religions qu'avec une
religion on va venir dans un instant et
c'est vrai qu'on procède peut-être un
peu papa s'était fait mention oui ça ils
tenteront peut on peut lier la ferme à
bilou qui alors qui est beaucoup plus
récente qui est de 2008 mais qui là
aussi c'est une femme qui porte un voile
qui le disons c'est parce qu'elles
portent un voile dans une crèche à
chanteloup les vignes
moi je voulais simplement ajouté à
propos de creil que
il ya eu sur le plan politique une assez
grande enfin une très grande
une très grande lâcheté moi j'avais eue
j'avais eu la chance alors pas à
l'époque mais c'est beaucoup plus récent
de rencontrer ernest chénière qui était
le principal du collège et qui m'avait
au cours d'une conversation extrêmement
intéressante confirmé ce que tout le
monde savait et l'a dit publiquement
depuis c'est qu'il a été totalement
lâché lâchés dans la nature seule par
les autorités académiques et puis par
des responsables politiques et notamment
quand le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
et puis sur le plan politique sur le
plan juridique bardon seul e le
gouvernement à l'époque a été pris entre
deux feux dans une espèce d'hésitation
le pré fait la frôle le soulignait tout
à l'heure entre d'une part la tolérance
la liberté et d'autre part le respect de
nos grands principes fondateurs
si bien que sur le plan juridique le
pouvoir politique
ici comme en d'autres occasions
d'ailleurs d'autres occasions gênante
c'est totalement dévoyé sur un avis qui
la demandait au conseil d'état et
conseil d'état d'ailleurs a fait
comprendre à demi mots ou pouvoir
politique qui lui appartenait de prendre
des décisions des décisions qui n'ont
été prises qu'en 2004 avec la loi
interdisant les signes religieux
ostentatoires dans l'enseignement public
donc tu as eu vraiment ici un dévoiement
des responsabilités qui est qui et qui
s'est avérée extrêmement dommageable
extrêmement dommageable par la suite
elisabeth badinter a raison elle résume
en une phrase
cette cette situation par par crainte de
l'intolérance nous avons tolérer
l'intolérable
voilà ce que ce que je voulais dire à
propos de creil on peut passer assez
vite sur la sphère de chanteloup les
vignes mais c'est qui vous happe le même
problème quelques quelques années plus
tard leur
bb écrit elle sur cette affaire de creil
oui tout à fait je crois que si on veut
approfondir le sujet est encore mieux
comprendre ce tournant c'est intéressant
d'aller d'aller lire les livres de notre
collègue laurent bouvet professeur en
sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines qui
a écrit deux livres récemment la
nouvelle question laïque ans en 2019 et
il approfondit l'inde est une des
thématiques convient d'évoquer ici
en 2020 il ya quelques mois le péril
identitaire paru aux édition de
l'observatoire
je crois que c'est ce qui est
intéressant dans livre qui gît là l'a
déjà dit tout à l'heure c'est que
laurent bouvet va montrer ce à
s'interroger sur ce tournant de 1989 ce
que ce que vous avez dit la chute du mur
de berlin et il va montrer au fond qu'on
est passé de cet âge totalitaire donc
fin des totalitarismes en europe le
libéralisme également qui va signer
aucune place pour les nouvelles
idéologies et on va passer à un nouvel
âge l'âge identitaire c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui ont été définis par toi
voilà par son identité culturelle une
identité religieuse dans sa communauté
voilà et dans l'iss 15 ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que laurent
bouvet revient sur ce qui va diviser la
gauche voilà sujet convient d'évoquer
qui va diviser puis aujourd'hui qui est
qu'on peut dire même éclaté et on voit
bien que c'est cette gauche issu des
pères fondateurs père républicain loi de
1905 elle est prise en tenaille en otage
au fond entre d'un côté aujourd'hui on
voit bien à l'extrême gauche
le discours des colonials anti les
indigènes et de l'autre à l'extrême
droite
eh bien les identitaires qui se sont
accaparés la question de la laïcité
malheureusement et avec là pour le coup
un discours profondément raciste donc on
et voilà on est un peu comme ulysse
entre charybde et scylla et puis on doit
naviguer dans ce voile alice's pour
protéger et bien ceux comme ainsi s'il
existe encore je reviens commun
domo à la sphère de la crèche baby loup
parce qu'il ya là encore c'est un peu ce
que vous disiez sur creil cdja la
division l'ald qui est la haute autorité
contre les discriminations avait jugé
que le licenciement de cette femme qui
portait le voile à la crèche était
discriminatoire et l'observatoire de la
laïcité donc il faudra parler qui est
présidé par jean louis bianco ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée avait
jugé et que le les atteintes à la
laïcité était surestimé dans cette
affaire on voit bien là encore un le
même par décembre 1989 c'est jospin qui
est ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous avez raison de rappeler
là encore ce sont des gens de gauche l'a
enfin là le fasse et pas forcément des
dévoila des des militants anti laïque
c'est on voit bien la division au sein
même de dos même camp oui et on voit
aussi les atermoiements et lacombe
l'obscurcissement en fête du jeu qui
devient incompréhensible pour les
observateurs extérieurs pour si j'ose
dire les profanes et pour tous ceux et
c'est plus plus important encore qui on
a travaillé avec la laïcité au quotidien
je pense en particulier aux personnels
de l'éducation nationale le plus
généralement tous ceux qui exercent dans
des services publics des services où on
accueille toute la société française
dont ou bien sur des questions de place
de la religion ne peuvent s'opposer la
sphère baby loup c'est des renversements
de jurisprudence permanences sont vides
et à l'innovation qui est voilà et ce
sont les acteurs publics qui prennent
des positions très très antagonistes les
unes avec les autres alors vous avez
cité la halde qui est don dont les
compétences ont été reprises par le
défenseur des droits vous avez cité
l'observatoire de la laïcité des
institutions d'ailleurs dont le statut
est d'un certain je pense en particulier
à l'observatoire l'a7 observé non c'est
pas dire un mot quand même parce que il
est extrêmement contestée par des l'oeil
quand même oui alors je
vous me posez la question je vais te
dire que il ya quelques sujets de
désaccord qui nous ont opposés des gars
ça comme ça non mais au-delà de ça ils
s'en sont du tout personnaliser le débat
je crois que ce n'est pas l'objet c'est
devenu la question est devenue non
seulement très très sensible ça c'est
évident mais assez largement illisible
et ça explique en grande partie la
raison pour laquelle pour les acteurs de
terrain le directeur d'école le jeu
c'est pas moi le directeur d'un et d'une
dune d'un établissement postale le le
patron d'un commissariat
le maire c'est devenu très compliqué de
s'y retrouver et donc comme ça brûle des
doigts on préfère s'abstenir
et c'est une des raisons qui expliquent
ce pas la seule
il ya aussi des arrière plan idéologique
c'est une des raisons qui expliquent en
truck ce qu'on appelle le pas de vagues
c'est à dire c'est ça quand tu ne sais
pas en fait si on a le droit ou pas le
droit de faire comme ci ou comme ça s'il
faut qu'on réponde très fermement ou au
contraire s'il faut essayer de composer
lorsqu'il ya une interprétation une
demande de porter tel vêtement etc
quand on ne sait pas à quoi s'en tenir
sur le plan juridique et que l'on entend
des acteurs publics en eau qui disent
tout et son contraire et des
jurisprudences qui changent en
permanence
c'est terriblement un certain et c'est
même un sécurisant donc c'est aussi ça
c'est mon avis un des grands mots dont
on a souffert c'est 15 20 dernières
années
c'est cette espèce d'un noyer
d'insécurité d'une certaine façon parce
que l'état ne sait pas exactement ce
qu'il veut en matière de laïcité
et effectivement les l'interventionnisme
de l'observatoire de la laïcité sur
certains sujets parfois en plein milieu
du vote d'une loi vous parliez de la
neutralité dans les associations et les
entreprises privées
ça a été consacrée par la loi et le
connerie en août 2016 et 20
l'observatoire de la laïcité est
intervenue en plein pendant le vote de
la loi pour dire qu'il fallait pas le
faire que ce n'est pas opportun
ça ça pose la question de fonctionner
une question de fonctionnement
démocratique est en tout cas encore une
fois pour les acteurs c'est très
perturbant qui dit le droit qui dit le
vrai sur la laïcité bas on sait plus
cédric françois pose la question mais on
peut être même soi même partagé sur
certains sujets ne pas forcément une
réponse définitive sur tout
je rejoins totalement ce que disait
gilles tu la vois là à l'instant pour
vous parler un tout petit peu de mon
parcours moi il ya trois événements
entre trois moments importants à la fois
lorsque j'étais effectivement
l'éducation nationale et depuis que je
suis maire j'ai vécu les attentats de
janvier 2015 alors que j'étais dans un
collège de poissy
ce 2 novembre 2015 dans un collège à
trappes et samuel pâtit alors que
j'étais maire bon et donc j'ai eu à
organiser avec l'éducation nationale
avec des consignes qui ne sont pas
toujours très claires de l'éducation
nationale voilà et qu il s est
d'ailleurs on renvoie à creil un qui a
été évoqué le poste creil c'était
souvent on renvoie aux personnels de
direction des établissements scolaires
le fait de dialoguer avec les jeunes
avec leurs familles pour essayer de
régler le problème du bruit mais voilà
c'était un petit peu ça alors voilà
alors jeune très honnêtement j'ai été
plutôt chanceux avec ma hiérarchie donc
je ne leur jette pas la pierre puisque
j'ai toujours eu à minima la liberté de
faire de mener les actions que je
souhaitais faire dans l'établissement
dans lequel j'ai exercé auparavant j'ai
travaillé pendant 12 ans en internat en
tant qu'enseignants et là c'est ce sont
des des endroits absolument pertinent
parce qu'on a le temps de dialoguer avec
les jeunes et leurs familles voilà où on
peut prendre le temps
moi je ne jette pas la pierre aux
enseignants qui ont un programme a mené
trop souvent d'ailleurs formé comme des
experts dans la transmission de savoir
et pas forcément dans leur dimension
éducative et donc non pas forcément
cette formation là voilà moi j'étais
détaché de la transmission directe en
classe puisque j'étais personnel
d'encadrement et donc je pouvais me
permettre effectivement d'avoir ce temps
de de dialogue avec les jeunes c'est fou
la terrasse et voilà et c'est compliqué
donc l'institution encore une fois je la
respecte profondément mes mais elle n'a
pas toujours été très clair vis-à-vis de
tous ces phénomènes comme avec d'autres
phénomènes d'ailleurs moi j'ai souvent
mené par exemple des ateliers avec des
adolescents sur les conduites à risques
où on abordait effectivement la
sexualité où on abordait les problèmes
de drogue etc
j'ai eu voilà je sentais une forme de
frilosité de ma hiérarchie par rapport à
toutes ces questions là or j'ai toujours
considéré que nous étions probablement
les mieux à même de de discuter de ces
questions là la frilosité par le
obstacles on va parler de votre rapport
quand même 2018
ok alors les les grandes pourquoi ce
rapport d'abord qui vous la demande des
7 je crois que ce ministère de
l'intérieur pour quelles raisons à ce
moment là il ya eu déjà un rapport
quelques années avant de françois baroin
qui avait été demandé par par jean
pierre raffarin quand il était premier
ministre
pourquoi il ce rapport en 2018 et et
pourquoi il a été accueilli de façon à
les polémiques
pourquoi il ya eu ce rapport je reste
très franchement je me le demande encore
j'ai eu mon sentiment c'est que ce
n'était pas très clair dans l'esprit
même de ce segment des grands qui ont
demandé bon je suis resté complètement
silencieux lors de la publication
d'ailleurs la fuite de ce rapport ce qui
a paru dans la presse ça soit un petit
peu bizarre parce que tout simplement
d'abord me l'a demandé et puis c'était
tout à fait normal j'avais pas commenter
ce rapport ne m'appartenait pas et
appartenait à l'administration
si kim en avait passé commande mais le
point le fait générateur c'est un avis
de l'observatoire de la laïcité qui est
passée un peu inaperçue parce qu'il a
été rédigé au moment de la passation de
pouvoir en mai 2010 est donc ce n'était
pas forcément au coeur des
préoccupations nationales et qui
pointait un certain nombre de faiblesses
pour dire les choses publiquement dans
l'organisation locale des politiques de
laïcité c'est à dire notamment les
relations entre les collectivités
locales les services de l'état et
d'autres institutions donc cet avis de
l'observatoire été transmis au ministère
de l'intérieur quelques mois plus tard
avec des préconisations qui était
d'ailleurs assez floue et pas forcément
très bien documenté sur les réalités de
terrain
mais mais je mets cet aspect là de côté
donc moi je passais par là au ministère
de l'intérieur avant de partir vers
d'autres aventures et on m'a demandé de
faire ce rapport parce que je m'étais un
petit peu penché sur la mission
auparavant
sachant qu'il pouvait y avoir des
interférences personnel
l'observatoire j'avais mis en garde en
disant attention ça va peut-être donner
lieu à des polémiques
quoique fin encore je n'avais rien
demandé à personne je ne recherchais pas
et je m'étais jamais exprimé
publiquement sur l'observatoire
et donc j'ai fait ce rapport en
travaillant de manière très classique
tout en étant de sol donc j'avais peu de
moyens mais en allant dans un certain
nombre de départements j'ai rencontré à
peu près 200 personnes des acteurs de
terrain pour l'essentiel des élus des
préfets des policiers des personnels de
l'éducation nationale des responsables
associatifs des religieux bien
évidemment et j'ai entendu un peu
partout la même chose c'est à dire que
au milieu d'une situation générale qu'on
peut qualifier de 2,2 tout à fait
correcte sur le plan de la laïcité qui
est enseigné qui est comprise qui
respecte et il y a des points de
difficulté que j'ai qualifiée de
raidissement identitaire ça correspond à
certains territoires
sans surprise les territoires de la
politique de la ville pour l'essentiel
et ça correspond à des interpellations
religieuse ou à des protestations de
contestation des gens qui sont dans la
quasi totalité des cas avec elle que
quelques autres
cannes est beaucoup plus marginaux liées
à des revendications de personnes qui se
présentent comme musulman donc c'est la
version radicale
de l'islam qui qui est en cause ce
constat effectivement il n'était pas
très nouveau puisque jean pierre robin
pour l'éducation nationale très
important 2004 avait déjà fait et là
aussi c'est un rapport qui a eu un à la
fois dont on a beaucoup parlé qui a fait
polémique mais qui a été conquis a été
un peu étonnant mis de côté voilà et est
en réalité depuis 2004 depuis lors la
situation s'est considérablement
aggravée et si je puis me permettre de
le dire aussi
depuis vous avez parlé des attentats
2015 depuis le moment charlie et même
depuis 2018 la situation s'est encore
détériorée et on en voit d'ailleurs les
traces dans un certain nombre d' enquête
là tout récemment il ya un un sondage à
paraître de l'ifop pour la licra et la
revue le droit de vivre et qui montre
que sur beaucoup beaucoup de sujets la
laïcité la liberté d'expression et aussi
d'autres qui alors qu'ils sont pas
forcément explorer dans cette enquête
bien dans certaines zones sur les jeunes
et la laïcité alors sur les jeunes et la
laïcité d'abord effectivement il ya un
effet de génération les jeunes ont une
vision plus tolérante east on va dire de
la laïcité il privilégie le droit de
s'afficher de s'exprimer c'est pas
surprenant ça correspond un peu à l'air
du temps c'est pas forcément dramatique
non plus d'ailleurs mais à l'intérieur
de la population lycéenne qui est
interrogé on voit que les réponses des
lycéens qui se déclarent de confession
musulmane sont en décalage avec avec d
autres très nettes par exemple sur la
contestation de la loi de 2004 sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux à
l'école refusé à plus de 80% d'une
majorité à john mack et pour le port du
voile enfants alors même une majorité de
jeunes qui est alors une courte majorité
49 % de jeunes en général qui sont par
exemple pour le port du voile
s'il s'agit du voile mais en réalité on
le dit c'est alors à seulement le port
de signes religieux par l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires des agents publics et une
très forte majorité de lycéens de
confession musulmane
autour de 80 % qui sont également de cet
avis alors là on est vraiment au coeur
de
la laïcité puisque la neutralité des
agents publics
sans ça il n'y a pas de laïcité que c
est pour ainsi dire voilà donc on voit
clyde il ya quand même un décalage de
dison de normes d'attitude de
représentation du monde très fort que
j'ai j'ai relevé récemment dans un
article
justement je suis votre la conclusion de
notre article a été publié dans le
figaro vote
vous dites apport grobon les jeunes on
peut comprendre mais finalement si
c'était nous des adultes qui manquions
de conviction c'est votre conclusion
je crois que c'est tout ce que nous
avons dit les uns et les autres depuis
30 ans depuis la sphère de creil ça
comme on dit familièrement cela coûte
retravailleront c'est pas clair alors
c'est moi je trouve assez normal que les
enfants les adolescents les jeunes se
disent au fond est ce que les adultes
savent bien ce qu'ils veulent dans cette
affaire où sont les convictions tels que
les expriment l'état les pouvoirs
publics les instituts nition les ceux
qui ont charge de transmettre
d'enseignés transmettre et basse ils
sont eux mêmes pas stable sur leur appui
et comment pourraient-ils l'être dans
les conditions qu'on a décrites c'est à
dire très incertaine est très sensible
sur le plan politique il n'est pas
complètement étonnant que les jeunes
soient dans ce genre de représentation
et s'agissant des jeunes musulmans parce
que là on a un vrai sujet et c'est tout
sauf de la discrimination que de le dire
au contraire pour moi l'attitude
vraiment discriminatoire c'est même un
peu gros descendante oui c'est dire ben
ali aucun sujet n'a aucun problème et
non il ya un vrai décalage de perception
un ressenti victimaire très profond qui
considère que la france globalement
refuse à aux musulmans leur place dans
la société
ça c'est un problème social majeur et il
s'agit bien évidemment pas et c'est ce
que j'essaye de dire en effet de porter
la responsabilité sur ces jeunes mais
bien au contraire que les adultes se
sont investis de cette question là parce
que c'est une alors là c'est une vraie
question de cohésion nationale
il est évident que cette jeunesse
française maintenant française depuis
deux voire trois générations que cette
jeunesse française doit être écouté
compris se sentir intégré et il est vrai
que les discours qui la travaillent en
permanence sur le mode vous êtes des
victimes la france ne vous aime pas la
république se prétend égalitaire mais en
fait elle est raciste
voyez ce qui était déjà le discours
qu'on entendait autour de la sphère de
craie il ya trente ans ce discours-là et
mortifère parce qu'il porte en lui les
germes du pour le coup d'un vrai
séparatisme au sein de l'ue au sein de
la société française jean pierre davant
ni justement or quelques mots nos
étudiants ont travaillé sur ce qui s'est
passé à trappes
quelle est la conclusion que vous
retired je crois qu'il fait une grande
différence entre l'expression écrite et
l'expression orale oui et alors d'abord
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire monsieur c les jeunes en
fait ne refuse un peu 24 les jeunes que
je vois qu'ils ont tous sont tous à peu
près majeur en première année de
l'université sont tous demandeurs de
débats et d'explications ils sont pas du
tout a refusé et je sais que de temps en
temps moi j'ai fait des débats en cours
sur le port du voile à l état de gens
autour de moi qui est un faux pas il
faut pas mais les deux filles qui
portait le voile était les premières
contente qu'on puisse parler du port du
voile me être contrée donc il ya une
demande de débat et c'est intéressant et
très récemment
j'avais tout le tout le groupe
réunis par heavy hélas par
visioconférence par disions cours et qui
m'ont demandé était plusieurs à ce qu'on
puisse consacrer la question de céder
une cour à ce qui se passait à trappes
avec ce professeur de philosophie
donc on a beaucoup travaillé là-dessus
et alors ils sont tous passionnés ils
sont tous passionnants la seule chose
qui est vraiment noté c'est qu'il ya
comme une sorte de chape de plomb
peut-être alors de politiquement correct
etc mais ce qui fait que personne ne
s'exprime oralement pour dire non pas du
mal mais pour avoir un discours un peu
dissonante d'en bas non vraiment il faut
en aucun cas le port du voile il ya tous
les gens s'expriment pour le port du
voile par exemple tous les étudiants
ceux qui sont contre ne s'est même pas
parce que il ya une sorte d'ambiance qui
fait que
ils savent très bien qu'ils vont vont se
faire pourrir entre guillemets pour
employer une une terminologie à la mode
donc ça c'est ce qui me trouble beaucoup
c'est cette espèce d'autocensure de peur
et qu'on ne retrouve pas dans des
devoirs que je leur donne de voir donc
par définition écrit hou la la parole se
libère beaucoup amusé et je lui fais
toute la classe n'est pas unanime a
encensé le fait religieux etc donc mais
ça ne se dit pas oralement parce que
visiblement il ya un discours normé et
que personne ne veut en sortir
donc il aime bien discuter il aime bien
que je prenne position il aime bien
qu'on discute mais il ya toute une
partie de la de la parole qui me paraît
confisqués enfin c'est une auto en
question parce que bien évidemment et
surtout leur censure vraiment tenter
justement on en attrape juste à côté de
guillon coup ça fait partie de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin
est-ce que
est ce qu'il y aurait des solutions à
votre avis est ce qui est ce qu'il faut
prendre le problème comment il faudrait
prendre ces problèmes un peu évoqué moi
je pense que ce don sera pas besoin et
je l' ai toujours pensé c'est de calme
et de sérénité
c'est à dire que je pense que le pire
c'est la polémique
voilà ça ne veut pas dire renier ce qui
se passe je les ai vécus pendant quatre
ans en tant que professionnel sur la
ville de trappes avec des adolescents
donc il n'est absolument pas question de
nier les phénomènes il existe et
d'ailleurs mon collègue maire de trappes
l'a dit sur un certain nombre de fois
sur les plateaux maintenant la polémique
c'est ce qu'il ya de pire parce que
lorsque tu rappes s'enflamme on ne sait
pas lorsque quand ça s'arrête
voilà et donc je pense que l'éducation
tous les acteurs vous l'avez dit un
monsieur clavel tous les atouts tous les
acteurs doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités et ne pas s'interdire
voir avoir une action volontariste pour
parler de laïcité pour parler de ces
phénomènes tranquillement voilà alors
vous ne pouviez pas le savoir même si
j'ai cru qu'ils avaient des fuites dans
mes services monsieur carmouze mais moi
j'ai fait le choix il ya plus d'un mois
maintenant de faire un magazine
municipal qui sortira à la fin du mois
qui sera celui d'avril sur la laïcité
donc vous voyez donc je pense qu'en mer
je pense qu'un maire peut aussi traiter
dans dans sa communication communal de
ce type de sujet et c'était un vrai
choix parce que je l' ai ressenti moins
comme ça je crois que c'est la bonne
période pour le faire sur l'action d'un
maire par exemple moi je passe
systématiquement voir les nouveaux
agents qui arrive dans la ville et je
les reçois au moment de leur recrutement
voilà ce sont des questions que je
j'aborde avec eux voilà pour m'assurer
qu'ils ont effectivement conscience
qu'ils vont en tant que fonctionnaire je
viens de la fonction publique d'état je
suis maintenant en charge de la fonction
publique territoriale
c'est la même chose pour moi bien
évidemment on est dans la fonction
publique et de ce devoir d'exemplarité
du fonctionnaire parce que j'y crois que
je l' ai vécu moi-même et je dois
m'assurer effectivement que tous ces
agents vont évoluer dans un contexte
qu'ils connaissent et s'il ne le
connaissent pas eh bien il faut le leur
expliquer voilà
donc je pense que chacun et notamment au
niveau de l'éducation nationale
d'ailleurs dans le magazine municipal le
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale des yvelines a
bien accepté de faire un article aussi
parce que je crois aussi à 7 à cette
collaboration bien évidemment il va
falloir conclure malheureusement il
reste moins de deux minutes je vais vous
interrogez comme sur quelqu'un dont on
ne peut pas dire qu'il ne défend pas la
laïcité service devrait on a parlé
beaucoup des caricatures de charlie et
il dit quelque chose dans un livre qu'il
a publié on peut tolérer les caricaturer
néanmoins s'inquiéter du carambolage que
celle ci suscite dans notre société
multiconfessionnelle et multiculturelle
un peu plus loin la messe debré dans son
propos en retournant un peu les choses
en disant non au blasphème n'en fait pas
un devoir
oui il va jusqu'à taxer des
responsabilités ceux qui seraient tentés
d'utiliser les caricatures comme
matériaux pédagogiques chez moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect et d'admiration on
l'est pour le pari pensent à leur label
l'esprit brillantissime de régis debray
mais parfois il va tellement loin dans
l'art du contre-pied qui finit par se
faire tomber lui même ses vannes mon
sens oui moi je fin j'étais étonné de de
lire ça sous la plume de régis debray
fin étonner ou à moitié
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'ai l'habitude
de de lire et puis que que j'apprécie
beaucoup et je voulais simplement dire
que oui oui l'effort éducatif l'effort
d'instruction de débat il est il est
encore devant nous il faut jamais
relâcher le l'effort et puis moi je je
je pense jeu
il m'arrivait parfois d'en parler avec
les étudiants de manière très libre
comme l'a dit jean charles tout à
l'heure en soulignant que la laïcité ce
ne sont pas que des interdits ce sont
c'est aussi une protection c'est aussi
un ensemble de garanties
et puis c'est un programme tout à fait
formidable qui permet de délimiter un
espace commun au sein duquel chacun peut
se peut se retrouver avec les autres
tout en se libérant de ses appartenances
spécifique ou particulières de saisie
dit et c'est laurent bouvet dans ses
bouquins dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
dans ces ouvrages ne dit pas autre chose
merci beaucoup et la télé qu'on aurait
pu faire buzzer et termine merci
beaucoup à tous
voilà bah je pense que on aura
l'occasion de reparler ces problèmes qui
sont évidemment passionnant et donc à
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]